you will walk ColdFusion PV hi welcome
to another ColdFusion video so this is
going to be a super quick video and
something a little different
I got inspired to briefly talk about
this topic because of something I came
across on LinkedIn of all places so I've
been pretty cautiously optimistic on the
concept of foldable phones and I can say
we're in a pretty awkward point right
now so looking at history if you compare
the progress of smartphones to the
progress of foldable phones where they
are right now we're at a kind of awkward
stage we could say we're at the PDA
slash business productivity device stage
of smartphones before multi-touch
capacitive screens were a thing today
foldable phones are clunky bulky and
perhaps useful but not to the average
person but I have something to show you
this is a concept for a piece of digital
jewelry called the bangle it was
designed by Danny Burnside at the London
firm square circle media it's just a
concept but this wristband got me
thinking that portable Curt and flexible
touchscreens
could be an awesome future I think the
UI design has a large part to do with it
danny has done a great job thinking
about this the UI is seamless fun and a
bit chaotic but obviously this could be
toned down for different tastes perhaps
if the aspect ratio wasn't as long as
depicted this device could serve two
uses the first use case could be a
digital assistant it would use specially
modified apps to fit this particular
form factor there'd be a heavy reliance
on voice control and it probably
wouldn't do as much as a smartphone but
it'll still do more than a SmartWatch
the second use case would be a smart
phone so say you could take the band off
unfold it and have a full smartphone
experience with web browsing and regular
app use it's not that hard to imagine it
also raises some interesting macro
perspectives about where we are in 2019
and where we're heading while a lot of
the tech community is focused on the
clunky foldable phones of today what
about the bigger picture
what if our current trajectory of
reaching reasonable practical foldable
phones is a path that leads to spin-off
technologies that make flexible form
factors more robust and cheap it's
analogous to the iPhone in
sense that in the decade after the
iPhones release capacitive multi-touch
made its way into laptops cars and other
kinds of displays say it's the year 2025
and something like this cost $200 and
has an all-day battery life I'm sure a
product like that would be flying off
the shelves and people wouldn't complain
that much so leave it up to you and ask
you the question what do you guys think
of a concept like this do you think it's
the dumbest thing you've ever seen kind
of cool or awesome I'll leave a poll so
you can buy it or leave your thoughts in
the comment section below so that was
pretty much it I just wanted to start a
discussion and what you guys think of a
future like this if you wanna see
another video on mobile technology I've
recently done a video on how Apple is
getting left behind and what they're
going to do next it's important to note
that that video is made before all the
foldable phone announcements last month
I'm also making an effort to post more
on Instagram so be sure to follow me
there anyway thanks for watching this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll see you again soon
for the next video cheers guys have
[Music]
cold fusion is he thinking
you